biden shows up camera's in tow and even
then he can't keep it together long
enough not to apparently look at his
watch i don't know what else to take
from that imagine if it were donald
trump all you would hear about is how
little donald trump obviously cares
about the troops and how much of a photo
op all of this is and all the rest joe
biden does it and we're supposed to
believe that he's captain empathy the
debacle in afghanistan is coming to its
semi-terminus tomorrow it is scheduled
to do so when all american troops are
withdrawn from afghanistan leaving
behind hundreds if not thousands of
american citizens and american green
heart green card holders and certainly
tens or hundreds of thousands of people
who worked with the united states
government during the last 20 years joe
biden for his part continues to not
answer questions it's it's an amazing
thing i mean
the fact that joe biden will not answer
simple questions about what's going on
in afghanistan where we're currently
going to be leaving behind again
hundreds if not thousands of american
citizens and certainly thousands of
american green card holders it's pretty
astonishing so yesterday while he was
making his announcements about hurricane
ida a reporter asked about afghanistan
and he simply refused to answer the
question and then sort of turn his back
on them
i'm not i'm not supposed to take any
questions but go ahead mr president on
afghanistan i'm not going to answer
again can you see if they're still in it
that's unbelievable i'm sorry that's
unbelievable he's the president of the
united states has no place to go he has
no place to go he simply just turns his
back on the reporter
that's amazing and then he actually is
directed the wrong direction he starts
to walk off in the wrong direction and
then has to walk back in the other
direction
this president is not competent he is
not with it he is certainly not capable
of running the country at this point in
time and that is perfectly obvious and
then in a bit of a debacle yesterday it
is being undercovered by the media
because if it were donald trump you know
it would be you know the the entire it's
amazing if this were donald trump this
would be the entire news cycle endlessly
because you remember that there was an
entire news cycle during the last
election cycle over whether donald trump
had visited a world war one cemetery in
europe and at the time had made
disparaging remarks about america's
fallen soldiers remember there's an
entire political news cycle and the
atlantic had covered it it was jeffrey
goldberg over the atlantic covering it
and it was all unnamed sources
imagine if donald trump had gone to
dover air force base to do the dignified
transfer
of bodies of the american service people
who had been killed in afghanistan and
imagine if he looked at his watch
really this is kind of an amazing story
so
this is not speculative here's the video
you can decide for yourself what joe
biden is doing here he doesn't look like
he's hitting his sleeve to me he looks
like he's deliberately looking down at
his watch and then realizing he
shouldn't be looking at his watch while
waiting for the bodies of american
service members who are dead because of
his afghanistan policy
that's an amazing and and the media have
thus far really not covered it
imagine if it were donald trump right
the callousness is the point the cruelty
is the point but joe biden
was structured in afghanistan policy so
absolutely incoherent that certainly
tens of thousands of people are going to
be slaughtered by the taliban certainly
americans are going to get left behind
and now he's at a place specifically
first of all
there's a general rule that if you go to
dover air force base to do the dignified
transfer of troops to be present for
that you don't let the cameras in
right that george w bush famously did
that george w bush famously went in the
middle of the night two dover air force
base dana parina talks about this she's
his press secretary she talks about the
fact that george w bush would go to
dover air force base quietly and without
the cameras there to do the dignified
transfer
biden shows up camera's in tow and even
then he can't keep it together long
enough not to apparently look at his
watch i don't know what else to take
from that like i haven't even heard an
excuse from the white house on what he
was doing there because in the video
it's pretty damn i mean i've looked at
my watch
from time to time when i'm bored with
something and it looks exactly like that
so that that's an amazing thing and
again if it were donald trump all we
would hear about is how little donald
trump obviously cares about the troops
and how much of a photo op all of this
is and all the rest joe biden does it
and we're supposed to believe that he's
captain empathy
i hope you enjoyed that clip from the
ben shapiro show if you did go ahead and
hit that subscribe button so you stay up
to date with all our future content